عميد الياس حنا فيما يتعلق بهذه الاتهامات
المتبادله بين الطرفين الروسي والاوكراني
بشان محطه سفروجيا ما واقعيه هذه
السيناريوهات استهداف هذه المحطه
والاثر والضرر الكبير الذي يخشاه كثيرون
ليلى اي حدث في هذه المحطه هو خاسر خاسر
للفريقين يعني هي من يقول انها ملكيته وهو
الاوكراني هو يقاتل في جوانبها ومن يقول
ان بعض ضمها المرسوم ضم الاربعه اقاليم من
الرئيس بوتين اذا تعرضت المحطه الى شيء
معين الى حدث مهم هو المتضرر الاساسي
اليوم منهم من يقارنها بتفجير
سدوفكا وهذا الامر مختلف تماما اليوم لا
احد يتحدث عن تفجير السد بينما اذا لا سمح
الله حدثت هذه
الحادثه قد تؤثر الى فترات طويله وسنوات
طويله على كل الاجزاء ضمنا الجيش
الاوكراني والجيش الروسي لو سلمنا جدلا ان
الجبهه انهارت والجيش الروسي نهارا باكمله
وبدا الانسحاب بالاتجاه الحدود روسيه قد
يلجا
الرئيس بوتين الى تفعيل العقيده النوويه
التي تقول التصعيد لخفض التصعيد واستعمال
النووي التكتيكي ولكن لا اعتقد في هذا
الوضع ان الامر يتجاوز التهديدات
والتهديدات المباشره اذا ترى ان كل هذه
العمليات وهذه الاتهامات بين الطرفين هي
مجرد ربما اثاره البلبله الاعلاميه لا
اكثر ولا اقل ام هناك شيء من الحقيقه في
هذه التحقيقات او
التهديدات اولا تفجير تفجير المحطه بوجود
رقابه دوليه وكاله الطاقه الذريه التي
قالت لا يوجد اي شيء ولكن انا اعتقد اليوم
ان المرحله القادمه هي مرحله شد الحبال
والتوقيت هو توقيت
الهجوم النووي الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
وبالتالي هي عمليه من ضمن العمليات كم مره
تم الحديث عن تفجير قنبله قذره الخطوره في
هذه المحطه انه ما يق
2200 طن من السبنتيول كما يقال لنا من
الفيول المستعمل والتخزين موجود قد يؤدي
الى قنبله خضره ولكن هذه القنبله القذره
ليلى هي المتضرر هو الجيش الاوكراني
والجيش الروسي ولكن هل الجيش الروسي معدل
قتال في اجواء
رضييشن او اشعاعات او نوويه الجيش الروسي
اليوم لا يستطيع تامين اللوجستيه لا
يستطيع ليس لديه الاليات الحديثه انا
اعتقد لا احد مجهز لهكذا حرب انها عمليه
يعني عرض الاصابع والاتهام والاتهام
المبادل ومحاوله نسخ صوره الاخر شكرا
جزيلا لك العميد الياس